[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
whoa oh hello there uh welcome to
community Fridays everyone has gone it's
it's your boys been in John Luke and
we're here and our new set up the
wonderful game spot studio we're stuck
we've upgraded there's a couch here
there's deep multiple giant televisions
we've got people jacob decker is in the
back switching for us say hi Jake
hello there he is yeah but today we're
gonna be playing Halo Reach on a PC
we've been talking about it since like
the middle of last year mm-hmm and it's
finally here we're finally able to do it
yep Jake why you switch over to our yep
there we are
how lovely all right guys so this is
your first stream with us community
Fridays up there the logo we play games
with you guys we're playing Halo on PC
we have a handy little guide we put yes
explain how to do it so the best way we
came up with is if you join the GameSpot
official steam group URLs right there it
you should just build to join there's no
Google process or anything and then you
join people or going up as I can see
there's already somebody here and then
from here theoretically you should be
able to click on my name and a thing
will pop up that says you can join my
game yeah we tried this a little bit
yesterday so the the whole PC set up is
a new thing we've done it stick out
successfully on ps4 successfully on Xbox
successfully on the switch PC is a new
frontier yeah we're gonna so bear with
us if there's any weird troubleshooting
issues a worst case scenario I will like
friend you and invite you and then I'll
probably tell you afterwards don't take
it personally if that is what happens so
yeah and also the good thing about
joining the group is that's probably
what will run all of our PC stuff out of
anyway mm-hmm so you're easy to get in
there bed it's got the chat Ben Ben can
monitor the chat I don't know if we want
to try and get
Zain here so think you've got to
actually go into the custom multiplayer
menu first I do i okay because that's
that's what makes the game join oh
really all right at least in my
experience user experience okay well so
you should be joinable now you
theoretically theoretically I should be
joinable and we'll know if our friend
who's in the group joins soon we will
see well say but yeah you should be able
to right-click on them and just either
start the game or join up yeah I mean
ideally I think what we'll try and do is
we will get if we can get at least like
one or two people in will maybe do some
online games and then once if we get
enough people in we're playing online
doesn't work we'll switch over to custom
and then we'll do some fun custom games
yeah yeah good time for all my the only
one here conga has joined true the
listen-listen tour for the game man in
complain if you want to play we're
playing Halo Reach on the PC here for
you guys it's it's finally happening but
yes yes I feel like it's been a while
since we had like a proper like
community Fridays because there's been a
lot of things that have popped up you
had a big thing happened last week by I
like move so that's why we didn't we
promised we were gonna do community that
week and then in the most time that I
had to move yeah they're they're like
you've got to move now you've got two
days getting yeah that was a stressful
week that feels like forever ago at this
point
dang alright no one yet let's see what
they're starting up we start up the game
they're on their way I'm not letting
this happen in real time will the
process work let us find out this is
this is the ultimate test
feeling if they join that I'm like cool
let's go we'll start up a thing wait for
other people to hop in yeah I got in it
worked
the system works everything's moved fast
okay I'm so happy so just to keep the
stream flowing then what we're gonna do
is we're gonna hop out I'm gonna bring
these people with me and we're gonna
play earth song yes yeah they are sweet
okay good good good so we're gonna play
44 let's that was Slayer some Bugsy's
yeah so we'll play some match made stuff
wall people kind of come in yeah so
basically while we're playing go ahead
and join the group hop in here and then
after this match we'll keep getting more
people in brudos dead says hey there
John Luke and Ben hello hi Bruno's dead
then Kenway asks how can I join so we've
got the the stuff listed down below but
to put it into words so it might be a
little bit easier to kind understand so
we have a GameSpot official steam group
that we're going to be running all of
our PC multiplayer community Friday's
out of so you join that group and then
you go into the group chat and then all
you do is right click on start us
crusader which is james steam name and
you should be able to join off of that
but yeah it's it's super super simple
so now that we've done this we've seen
it run through multiple times is the
Xbox version the easiest to deal with
or is this one's pretty good this one's
pretty easy Xbox was mostly easy it's
like in theory it's easy but then the
Xbox you I just been kind of trash
causing problems if I it worked almost
too well until it broke yeah and we had
Playstations probably the most difficult
also PlayStation I'll have to get like
eight people in there some real short
I think Xbox let's give you more Cloud
Strife save some halo I love me some
halo man cloud knows what's up you can
expect a lot of halo this year because
they're slowly going to be putting out
each halo game from the Master Chief
collection on PC so will probably join
back come back to those each time they
put out a new one yeah
through culminating to the releases of
just halo all the time yeah and then of
course we've got infinite coming out at
the end of the year which I'm very
curious about yeah it looks good
I like that they've taken it back to
kind of like the the older art style
yeah at least for like the armor you
have to forgive me I'm getting my groove
back here that's okay it's been a while
since this came out it's been a while
since we've played but it's a good time
to remind people that on community
Fridays if you're worried about not
being good enough or too good it doesn't
matter either way we're kind of just
hanging out to have a good time we've
the best one is fighting games cuz I
love it when someone who plays like a
fighting game and knows they're very
good it's like I'm not gonna join this
because yes not at the same level and
having them still come in we learn
things we get to see really cool combos
and like Mortal Kombat because there are
people out there who just know it way
better than yeah we're like 100% okay
that he was working us yeah so yeah
don't worry about it either way Jake
just linked the the steam group directly
if you want 200 settings here I feel
like my sensitivity is not I'm gonna
blame everything on the game's eco
sensitivity then you get you go I don't
have my yeah I prefer control settings
or so that might be the control settings
I think are good yeah more is it good
good sensitivity I've also so I was just
playing with my girlfriend for the first
time halo 1 we're like going through all
the halos so I'm like kinda used to the
way halo 1 feels so it like it takes a
second cuz like every Halo game actually
kind of feels pretty different from one
another yeah it's it's also a weird
thing that kind of like I've been
playing a lot of doom 26 Alaska's top
dog your boy is very excited for doom
eternal
if you want to get more about doing
internal stuff we've been talking about
our podcast it when there we go double
kill now we're back in it yeah there you
go but I should check out the podcast
Daniel Dwyers on they're talking about
doing but I'm excited for doom so
complain a lot of that and that's a very
different fps it's a halo and we played
like for like ten five or ten minutes
yesterday when we were getting
everything set up and I was like oh god
my controls are all wrong
sensitivity is all wrong be shotgun
beats sword every time I love being on
and take this so word heck yeah this is
fine
but Connor says hallo everyone I like
that
perfect top dog dang I repeat we have to
enter for joining yes just what what
Jake linked up well in between games
we'll go out and we'll check and see
who's in them yeah well get more people
on and the things squat more people
indoors and we'll see if we can get some
some custom games going just last was in
halo 3 halo 2 we had you know full party
oh yeah we had we did a xbox one and we
had a full party people and that was a
lot of fun people really seemed to have
a good time about to it eventually just
got to the point where everyone was just
talking about how much they love halo
and yeah that's a real wholesome
wholesome stream it's like oh man play
doing lamb parties hanging out with my
friends staying up way too late yeah it
was a good time dude Brandon says hey
guys great podcast by the way just
finished watching it
heck yeah Brandon and uh welcome to the
stream by the way yeah that was a very
good episode of podcast I was switching
in the back and I was uh I was
thoroughly entertaining the whole time I
haven't gotten a chance to watch or
listen to it yet but I'm excited to this
weekend I do a lot of my like my viewing
of our content that we make during
weekends right so it gives me a good
kana like where did they go oh it's bad
yeah I do
wolf station those days playing back
with my friends
what's that video it's like that ASMR
video yeah it's just a screenshot of
like a 360 playing Halo and it's called
like playing Halo 3 with the boys while
listening to like Lincoln Parker's like
Evanescence or something like advised
it's just like really quiet in the
background and you hear like the man
you're just you're like Slayer Killa
infer I'm gonna screw take this those
aren't even good tea bags now no they're
too quick yeah you gotta really like
that's real amateur move
but I'm just gonna throw it out there
he'll reach is genuinely my favorite
halo-halo reaches Hillary lastic top top
oh good the story fantastic
I love the the addition of the armor
abilities they're pretty good
they even had that weird like
battlefield type mode I didn't play it
too much but it was kind of an
interesting idea to have more people and
like an objective thing to be to did a
bunch of people quit out I think I was
just too v2 from a start Haley I'd said
it for four before oh I've heard that's
okay
that's fun alright let us see long back
out bring the party with us of course
okay let's see if anyone else yeah
someone here
alright guys might have enough to
actually do like a free-for-all all of
you hop on into our thing so I think you
might need to go back out on a custom
again I'll try it bring them with me
custom halo is the joining thing I think
we do have one yeah there we go
I assume that is uh math oh yeah I think
this is this is enough people to kind of
launch off and uh yeah so we get bug box
yeah see the people starting it up yep
there we go this is happening do this is
way he's here
remember armor lock ruining all my
killstreaks armor lock was a was a wild
time so I mean maybe people who are more
in tune with house teams like group
stuff works knows but like out my worry
with Halo is that when you go to game
sessions the only option it gives you is
friends only or invite only and I was
like well this isn't gonna work
yeah yeah but despite the fact of the
privacy set to friends only people are
able to join yeah I think that might
just be like it overrides it or
something like and then we were also
trying to consider like what doesn't
take into account Xbox Live all right
okay we got four black box girls
enjoying maybe I'll wait like 30 seconds
to see if I hop into the game I think
you can join in progress
- can you yeah well we have enough to do
do we so do we want to do a for all you
want to a free from
you're really putting me under the under
fire here aren't you
it's you know sometimes she's got a
slayer yeah I will go old G Slayer I'm
not doing boardwalk though um out of the
boneyard no no no no no reflection
reflection is flashes top to your map
what's the difference here ones made by
343 I literally do not know the
difference okay
yeah right 25 is fine I think it's it's
a little high but I mean it's try it
let's see how we feel bad yeah but I I'm
pretty sure people should be able to
join wall we're going we'll see so let
us know bug if it works for you if not
we'll we'll just us get this up by the
way once we get enough people in can't
join please help join the group what
part of the what part of the very long
process is it falling apart for you
that's I guess the troubleshoot it and I
able to join the group are you and I but
a group chat get the game installed
Oh Daniel also says they love the
podcast excellent I I love the long cast
like how well though the podcast does on
on YouTube I like to be able to see it
as an option it's kind of cool ok I keep
it clicking in on the stick to sprint I
hate it yeah I I feel like clicking in
the stick should be like the natural
thing but I've played where left bumper
alright somebody already took the sword
isn't a thing got a shotgun up top yeah
I felt for that it's that sword
I fell for that that clone that was a
clutch play yeah that was all
intentional hunter Brazil
there we go now we're in it get game
battle hype going looks super relaxed
Bob Jones I would be real with you
moving into this this new set up with
this couch I've never been more
comfortable on a live stream ever yeah
this is great I can't go back it also
has there's a really nice oh I got
tricked that's twice I also got ripped
off I should have I should have thought
of that
also I reached back here behind the
couch and I'm gonna destroy the illusion
there's just trash back here it's a
couple boxes we still need to unpack
we've got a very good outwardly like a
clean look but I'm gonna let you guys
know that we're still there's still
stuff going on there like three boxes
I'm pitching right now where are they oh
god oh god I knew I was playing with
fire when I went after them we're having
a great day I hope you're having a great
day too Ahmad thank you for stopping by
community i days is like the much fun my
favorite thing that I look forward to
I'm really glad that we're like I feel
like in 2020 we're ready to like do it
you know with the new new place where
we're doing it from we've got plans we
know what we're doing next week we've
got Plato's we do know we're doing a
semi schedule happening Oh God that's
dangerous just just making like a
straight that is a risky loadout but I
respect it yeah I need a weapon Call of
Duty League starts today I'm curious see
how it'll do I haven't seen anything
about the college ooty League
okay enough attention eSports really is
just like not yeah the one that caught
me off-guard was I didn't realize that
the League of Legends like soft launches
today they have a car game - yeah they
have a card game and a fighting game
coming out right I know about the
fighting game yeah apparently the card
game is pretty okay my roommate was
playing it yesterday yeah I think I'm
just kind of over card games I'm not
smart enough for him so I can't now
there's too much of an investment play
Halo Reach in roblox what if we did do a
roblox day just for like Jo like what if
community Fridays falls on like an April
1st and we say we're gonna play Counter
Strike global Offensive but it's just
like a Counter Strike global Offensive
modern roblox you know sure yeah just do
some wildlife I'm down but yeah if there
are any games that you guys are actually
looking forward to this year or games
that you want us to play should let us
know about them to cook
otherwise it's probably gonna be
whatever new releases happen that are
pretty big and John Luke and I just
playing a bunch of anime fighting games
in cable oh man I feel like I'm letting
myself down here I'm in last place
three planets an interesting start to
the year right Bob it's wild
okay see this isn't gonna help because
I'm terrible December you see that but
you got the kill it was a revengeance to
yeah coming up the lift maybe you're
wrong around that actually called
revengeance
no it's that's true
Joker does release on Tuesday but the
thing is so does violent and smash so we
were thinking was we are thinking about
doing viola
yeah let's listen will do by lift and
then we can hold off on normal combat
until later on and then people will be
able to just style on us with Joker for
an hour and a half and it'll be a good
time yeah we got two fighting games and
then granblue might be coming out I
don't know what the release date is here
still granblue and under night on switch
both came out the same week that's gonna
be a lot too we got a new character a
lot of fighting games gonna be happening
here on community Fridays yeah you know
is our bread and butter well you guys we
livestream the single-player campaigns
your fear one and twos expansion packs
extraction per season you know what
that's a hell of a play that's a lot of
fear on some real old-school I really
liked fear though I actually never play
I own both those expansions but I never
play them so my best memories of playing
multiplayer extraction points good I
heard Percy's mandate was not that is
kind of what I remember - vaguely
but the the best thing about fear was
doing like hand hand fights
I like the slow-mo like jump kick II
kind of [ __ ] yeah that's that's kind
of all I remember of that and also in
the first game when you climb down the
ladder and you see the girl at the top
of it
that still scares me
thinking of getting tempt how many
thoughts on that yet have you got a
chance to play it I haven't had a chance
to play it so I played a little bit o it
that was really good station real gut
this ever on there on there good
i I've enjoyed what I've played I'm
excited to find more time to play more
of it obviously but it it does a good
job kind of like if you've finished like
sword and shield you want to do
something in-between the new expansions
coming out it's got some really cool
things that I kind of wish Pokemon will
pick up on to but dang that was a good
one thank you
it's a good time it's it's a good like
monster catching game if you love
Pokemon you'll probably have a very good
time with it
oh can we find a way to make community
Fridays work for Animal Crossing your
stand by people I don't know what the
multiplayer is like for it but I mean
I'm like I used to figuring it out I've
seen a lot of villagers hanging out
online okay Friday's town that people
can join and mess around with oh man
gigs got a a good idea I like that
that's that's the content that's what a
community Friday village we come in it's
just a bunch of chopped down trees holes
everywhere and pitfalls it's a real mess
you see he's on top of that he's kind of
get me I almost never use the decoy
double got you Oh Oh woman steal what
steal it yeah yeah no kill oh yes I feel
really bad because I take it an
assassination it's really cool and hey
man everything got got thrown off the
window that was his mistake for trying
to do he shouldn't have gone for the
assassination that's the gamble yeah
yeah ah might be saying some NDA stuff
nah we're I love him now
we don't know anything about crossing I
wish people well the other game that's
coming out around that time that I
definitely want to do is do do because
it's got that like versus mode that
sounds awesome but also has the like you
can invade another person's god that's
really good the invading thing I want to
like do a stream or we just play the
game and people just keep trying to
invade us yes people line up to try to
stop us I think that sounds awesome it's
it's such a cool idea and I hope it
works in the way that we think
that's me too cuz it all it'll be a fun
time I think and heck maybe we'll even
like switch it you know whoever whoever
kills us might get to try to be the doom
Slayer and we try to stop them it's only
3 people total yeah what the other doom
thing ya did
David's throwing out that it might be
we'll follow the diverse is definitely
is I mean we would we would uh birthday
people in it oh yeah it's the idea see
as a guy who grew up with Halen reaches
my personal favourite reaches a very
good favorite a laugh - probably three I
think that was like the peak timing for
me when I played the most three so I
think I've played the most of three but
my favorite multiplayer is too
it's something about the speeds yeah I
I've definitely played more three but I
would say I from downtown that was good
wolf station just taken this match away
they're ready for the came here to play
but reach was also one that I played a
lot and I have a lot of good memories of
it with my friends that used to play
with in high school a lot we played
through I think three was the big one
millimeter actually in college yeah and
then we all kind of came back for for
reach I mean obviously any of the Halo
games if that's your favorite more power
to you but I'd say two three in reach
are like safe like oh yeah like you say
that's your favor I'm like agate yeah
totally loved I love to so much to is
real good I'm excited to play two with
my girlfriend now that we just beat one
ones campaign doesn't hold up as well I
don't think it's so fun to go through
it's not fun to go through but that
second half is is not as good as that
first half oh that's second half that's
kind of rough spots or smash my hot take
her sweet switching boy Jacob Decker
says halo 2 is his favorite never forget
picking it up at midnight
look at all these people join us come in
alright we are back we're ready for more
people to join get in here let's see we
already have a 3 so 1 2 3 4 5 6 so we at
least two more people can join that's a
that's a good a good point I I really
did like the campaign in Halo 2 up until
the end oh yeah sure they just ran out
of time and the settings need a whole
bunch of like cool like here's like some
town settings and a lot of really cool
set set pieces I'm at the ending kinda
just it took a lot of the wind out of my
sails
I'm real stoked that the multiplayer
held on for as long as it did
alright so we're just gonna wait for two
more guys to join in that are currently
waiting Jaden says sick hydrogen sick
very sick indeed it's two Chooch but my
former years formative years upon
playing three and reach yeah
halos is a big thing I'm very curious
about infinite yeah that game it's gonna
be like we I still feel like we haven't
seen like a lot of it we haven't seen
any of it we saw that like cutscene and
they're in like the ship and yeah Master
Chief is there that's that can only do
so much for me I need to gameplay I need
to see I want me to have I need to see
someone control it with their hands then
you see it running which you know
obviously we will see this year cuz it's
supposed to come out they go a launch
title well this is a good question that
we can actually answer and it might
actually help a couple of people decide
to get in if they want to yeah Connor
asked can you just by reach on peace
here do you have to buy a whole Master
Chief collection no you can just you can
buy reach by reach for like 5 bucks 10
bucks and enzymes maybe it's 10 bucks
for reach and I think it's for yeesh for
the whole thing yeah it's a better deal
definitely to buy the the whole deal but
if you just want reach it's not too much
of an ask I guess
yeah you can just get reached by itself
it's it's like listed as a DLC but okay
well I guess suppose it's hopping
because that other guy join in there's
still someone else who was we're waiting
on but we'll keep it moving they can
happen later do you want to keep on
Slayer or do we want to mix it up I
think it might be safe to still kind of
Oh unless you want to do like like a
juggernaut or an infection or an oddball
[Music]
most of Slayer from the minutes cuz we
still got like the odd number of people
yeah we'll do that yeah cuz we do have
an odd number that that's true maybe
we'll stick a slaver for that purpose
but I'm gonna switch maps up um so it's
good what's that good map chickens away
Battle Creek I do not like reaches
virgin behind them which is hanging high
battle canyons good zealots a classic
anchor 9 it's not bad either a little
big you ever get a reading version of
cheer on I don't even remember I'm sure
we did let's sell it yeah that's a fun
one I think that's been like every Halo
game since 2
all right let's do it yeah this is like
a weird take on it it's got a whole
bunch of like extra outside stuff but
right I love it yeah because I think
this is like this isn't five at some
three
I forgot the original name of it is well
I think like the original original was
midship but it's a little bit midship it
doesn't have the it still has like the
same design but it doesn't have like the
floating thing in the middle and there's
a lot more like running area really I
murdered the wreath the five version
because it was on the in the beta yeah I
wasn't you mind going back to five this
multiplayer again for a little bit I
like fives multiplayer here Jake Jake
does confirm that Master Chief
collection is $40 and reaches ten oh
thanks Jake perfect everyone's about
that that decoy life yeah I didn't
realize that like the hidden meta that I
never knew I maybe I'm like my problem
is that I'm just like I'm so used to
sprinting that it's no I need the spray
I need it which is the one thing I like
about hey before I stop the one thing I
like about how before it is a thing I
like about Hitler for face
they just made sprint a normal thing
all the fights happening Oh God for
needles ah ooh yeah no I I was always
maybe like 80 or 90% of the time I've
always used sprint and I'd use jetpack
occasionally never in slow yeah that's
the big player if you're just a target
armor lock was fun in big team and I
played a lot of big did you do a lot of
that we know they made their like
invasion yeah did you do that I'd do a
lot of it but occasionally it'd be fun
to kind of go into I think it never
worked for me because just they're like
what the amount of players it's like
only 16 and the map is so huge like it
just never quite worked the way I feel
like it [ __ ] oh you know just so well in
titanfall to that I guess people just
rediscovered that decoys are great in
Halo that that's that's a good call
we're titanfall 2 2 they made it a free
to plot you know or not free to play it
was some PSN's game for like a hot
minute December I want to say yeah yeah
I think I actually bought it and own it
on PC Xbox and ps4 at this point yeah I
don't know if it's still that way but I
know that when it went free for
PlayStation Plus it did have a nice
resurgence
how's it going DT welcome I'm really
glad that there are a lot of grunt
birthday parties happening bats to do
all the real stuff
it was was that a deflect I don't know
cuz it looked like it might have been
I also kind of like the bit of recoil at
the beach oh good effort some armor lot
caused me so much rage you have a guide
down to one shot and they would activate
it and his team would just pick you yep
that's exactly how it go
I liked it for big team specifically
just because I love having someone
trying to run you over and then you get
that one small moment where you're able
to armor lock in front of it oh yeah I
fell for that I felt for that hard I
didn't realize you could actually lock
onto it with a melee that's oh alright
brilliant they got me dang man it's 2020
is the year of the the distraction I
guess for we're in there yeah just that
that one brief moment where you be able
to stop out this time yeah I got him he
must have arty been weak that wasn't
that that's good any kill the other is
good as long as there's that explosion
Dini looks great ever since three
nobody's gonna get meals here boy why
can't we find out why I'm random FPS
drops oh this game I can't no I can't
troubleshoot it professionally or
anything but I guess try to do some some
routine maintenance on your PC do like a
like a cache clear something to like
turn off certain settings that may see
if anything's running in the background
yeah I actually solve a lot of my
problems with games is all actually
going to the steam forums for whatever
one it is and search whatever the
problem is the importance are usually
pretty good for troubleshooting cuz
people go to steam forums for two things
it's finding out how to fix their issues
with their game running or engine
complaint because the game isn't running
right yeah so you're able to usually
find pretty good info if you try that
out there might be something there that
is my my recommendation to you and I'm I
feel bad that I can't give you any more
advice on how to fix it
oh ah maybe I'll just get a name you're
probably not Oh next box gamers who have
no idea
eight that's the nice thing about
consoles you kind of just you know just
go yeah
oh I'll take it I'm glad that van made
it in I didn't even notice them until
just now oh yeah they were the last
person who just joined will those see
you guys play half-life 2 deathmatch and
Team Fortress 2 ooh we were talking
about for fun like a counter-strike
playing oh yeah we wanted to play
counter-strike 1.6 at one point we
thought would be really fun
you know half-life 2 deathmatch or Team
Fortress might be an interesting because
the thing to do like around half-life
Alex come yeah oh that would be actually
really fun to kind of be like hey let's
do like a multiplayer yes I have our
locking valve themed thing let's all
play some half-life 2 deathmatch let's
all throw toilets at each other
wallplate will just play ricochet let's
do a month of ricochet
that's true that's another good
shout-out that they would put out the
half-life series is completely free
right it is that's actually up until
Alex comes out so I'd say the things
that we look for when we pick games to
play for community Fridays is
relevancies it's something new like the
game just come out - they just have a
new mode or DLC character or expansion
and then other examples are is it free
to play now is it like on PlayStation
Plus so they haven't a free weekend
that's always a good opportunity to UM
hop in games like that but if you
eventually get to a point where it
doesn't matter what we play that's when
I get to leave [ __ ] out that's what I'm
saying hey everyone load up their copies
of Assassin's Creed Black Flag cuz we're
playing the multiplayer which I one day
one day we should do that
I love the Assassin's Creed multiplayer
and I'm sad that Black Flag was the last
one to have it do i I do to it nothing
feels better than like pulling someone
like and do a hay-bale and just doing so
guys I got really good at that
multiplayer - oh I don't forgot like
really good but I had I had some very
good times
and I'll admit I actually had some
pretty good time with the dead space 2
multiplayer - that one I never played
because I at the time I rented the game
she needed the password and I didn't
have that pass and then will by the time
I actually went and bought it no one was
playing anymore
yeah it was kinda like a weird like
slower left4dead
kind of multiplayer I think right but
yeah any type of assassin's creed
multiplayer I got to think of of that
cuz I played them I think both at the
same time
yeah all right where we at here one two
three evil project okay we got six
people yeah so so it didn't join mid
game I think but yeah do we have any
more people that are trying to join bug
boxes back online they were okay so
let's give him another minute or so see
if people are ready to join but we got
six now so we could we do team so good
we can break it up to I think we'll
maybe able to switch over into a team
thing see Bob brings up an interesting
point Dragon Ball fighters is getting
another Goku so we could do that again
yep yeah we did Dragon Ball that was a
fun one Dragon Ball dreible is a really
fun one because it's it's kind of easy
to do but yeah it's also fun oh one last
never mind
back to five
ooh yeah come on isn't there supposed to
be some sort of co-op in the new
Assassin's Creed game that's what
they're saying in the weird ventus
you're asking how to join you just need
to hop into the game and then click on
my name in the group chat and yeah I
joined again let's do a right-click on
it say join it should work
[Music]
sonic 521 asked the most important
question what's your favorite level from
your favorite Halo game for me I it's a
toss-up between
Blood Gulch cuz it's it's like the
classic like some sort of like
symmetrical asymmetrical
capture-the-flag map there are two bases
there are multiple iterations on it so
you've got multiple options and whenever
I think of Halo that's the map I think
of
lockout ivory towers driver tower I also
like midship from Halo 2 specifically a
lot only because I play really well on
it okay yeah but I still think halo 2 is
probably my favorite cuz a lot of those
maps kind of just pull from there anyway
vengeance no I do not need to accept
friend requests you should just be able
to join yeah you might need a you might
need to start the game up first I don't
know if that's it should let you join
right away but you should be able to
also join from start the game up see if
that'll work
alright we'll give it another minute and
then we'll start up the next match oh
I'm more meant from story now
multiplayer but that works to a story
though
[Music]
I think the moment in in 3 where you get
the tank and you get that tank beats
everything line from Halo 3 yeah like
that that whole sequence of just being
in the tank and shooting things yes is
really fun I like any of the stuff in
like new Mombasa I really like when Halo
does like urban stuff
what's the line from a Halo 2 with the
tank
I think it's on because though the line
he says changes depending on which
difficulty I forget if it's heroic or
legendary where Johnson says back when I
first joined the Marines we only had two
sticks on a rock and we had to share the
rock and I love that they have that I
would have been your daddy skull that's
changed no ventus's they don't have the
steam version
oh no so that one then yes you would
need to friend me on xbox you'd have to
follow my gamertag so here follow me on
xbox at
[Music]
forty-two okay so there you go in that
case I'm gonna start up ventus and while
you try and troubleshoot that and
hopefully join and we'll just keep
playing a little bit here what's another
good map to play was there's another
like shadow that you gotta do for like
the really atmospheric halo levels where
they they start off with like a really
ominous thing and it's darker oh yeah
Beavercreek anniversary surprise try
that one I don't know of differences
chick says the first orbiter mission is
rad first our mission is rad and the
halo free mission where you take down
the scare is also very good ooh guess
the halo three one oh the arc oh there
you go they just followed me so that's
so weird to see all that I know I'm all
these different things hopping up Delta
halo there's a sniper jackal on a
waterfall soca music kicks in what your
comments yeah there are so many good
good moments
my favorite title card level intro is I
forget what the title card is but I
remember the quote and it's right after
they start glassing everything yeah and
you see a ship off on the horizon and
everything's kind of low Oh Sam can't
waste a juggernaut I'll take that I'll
take that let's do that yeah do that
turnouts fun but you see like the ship
off the distance and you hear one of the
the the covenants say over like the
comments like arbiter this is the shadow
of intent the name of the ship is shadow
of intent oh yeah that's that's such a
badass name for a ship they have really
good ship names in Halo I don't know it
okay so this one is bloom is reduced and
bleed-through is enabled I do not play
enough to her or not to note that means
bloom is probably for weapon shooting
and bleed-through is when you melee
someone in there at like the tail end of
there she should take their shield and
all their health away which one should
we go with then um let's keep it bleed
through not enabled okay so let's do
classic then cuz I want I want the
juggernaut to like hang on
all right let's do it
yeah having the scheme's oh so it's not
Gamestop but it's gamespot so if you
search on Steam
GameSpot official you'll you'll find but
it was Game Stop you just hijacked I
mean stop Peter gave Peter was running a
Game Stop steam group maybe pretty good
that was so funny yesterday we're trying
to set it all up and put the link in
there thing we were trying to get that
juggernaut oh god take my bed it's all
good we sometimes will have to retake
videos because we'll see Game Stop
instead of GameSpot oh I wasn't gonna
say though oh yeah when we were trying
to with Peter because we were like well
we'll make a steam group and they were
like oh we already have one well Peter
was the owner and so we messaged him and
he's like like hey can you make us like
admins in the steam group he's like I
don't think I have the power to do that
and I'm like uh it says you own the
group what we just didn't remember it
was like that long ago but yes so we're
we're gonna bring back the steam group
make anything I know if you could like
melee him
I don't want to risk yeah there we go
Oh God I move too fast Oh where's game
stop so you don't know what game stop is
it's uh it's a video game retailer
they're they're kind of kind of
everywhere ish but it's a real
unfortunate thing that our our website
name is very close to their name and I'm
sure they also know its first mixed up
oh that's a good question we probably we
could do some research figure out who
who lays claim to the K best phonetic
sounds those able let's say YouTube
premium is so good for minimizing and
still hearing you guys I wish it weren't
twelve dollars a month well man that's a
cool feature that's really that is a
bummer that it makes you do that though
I I didn't know that that was a feature
that YouTube premium had yes because
it's meant for PT if you wanna listen to
music through YouTube so the it wasn't
like I've always thought it was them
just not knowing how to program no yeah
they knew how does they know how to
program they just locked it out they
locked it out oh yeah
super yeah that's that is a lot but I
appreciate that you're still here
listening to us that that makes me real
happy
murdered oh shoot
jake has done the research and this
found out that gamestop was founded in
1984 aware his GameSpot was 1996 oh she
don't have any claim to the Sangh we
hate to see it
besides having sown in the backer can
actually like fact check yeah I
appreciate this this is good we should
we should have like a fact checker
computer just good outside said he was
sitting in one of the trees next to this
I have like out like an Alexa or a serie
or something like oh I can't run down I
could have just hate her hold my phone
but we've also got something better
though we've got Jake I think the
correct answer would have been we would
get a Cortana oh yeah
what am I thinking actually I think the
retiring Cortana because oh yeah because
like most Microsoft things nowadays no
one uses it we're just kind of sad it
was a cool idea
yeah Microsoft's kind of in a weird spot
with a lot of their stuff where Sonic
5:21 says yo real talk do you guys
remember tech TV g4 oh yeah of course
love to explain yes all that programming
was fantastic
Atem Sessler i used to it was it was
like a ritual
oh those cold-blooded I was about to I
was about to rock you on him three
cahoots he's gonna rock him me anyway Oh
tragic yeah it was it was an
after-school ritual to come home and sit
down and watch tech TV and then g4
eventually when it became a g4 tech TV
extended play ax
'we Cinematheque their e3 coverage was
fantastic it made you feel like you were
really there but I was weeping right now
see they also did like an anime walk
Muhsin thinking of something else
Fredrik keep the politics out of the
chat or I will remove you what minutes
remaining
yeah we don't we don't need that mess
we're here to have fun and talk about
Halo and other weird things Tony that
pops up in the computer yeah that's what
we're talking about
that Cortana like a tell me when we were
founded there's a Clone Wars new series
happening I haven't watched Clone Wars
rebels yet and I probably should
especially now that I have them like
Clone Wars anti rebels are both very
good haven't available to me now like I
have I have Disney Plus I should
probably like just do it
but well the first thing I watch on
Disney Plus was I've had like a
subscription oh god I had the
subscription for like a month and a half
now and I watch my first thing like last
weekend and it was Toy Story 3 for the
first time and I hadn't had any of it
spoiled for me that movie odd hits right
oh it hits hits hits real hard when
you're definitely like I'm a dollar yeah
ice when it came out in theaters I was
it was literally this summer I was about
to head off to college oh yeah so I was
like man if I gotta went home and found
all my toys and hugged them look he'll
never say anything bad about you ever
again oh my favorite
yeah like I hadn't had anything smoked
for me except for like the the thing
that happens at the garbage area I'm
trying to like not be too descriptive in
case Aventis got in fantastic heck yeah
so I knew like that was happening to
know what happened because of it and I
thought oh no this is the sad part it
wasn't even that sad you know like
whatever and then everything after that
alright so now we have enough well how
many people you got one two three four
five six seven no I am watching the
mandalorian though it's everywhere
everyone knows a good bit of zombies a
Mandalorian is really good I need to
still I'll check if anyone's given any
recommendations well Faust is in the
chat your boy my boy Faust did he looks
crazy yeah what's a good zombie map
a breakneck that's that is like a city
yeah number AB Mads a little too big but
spring next a great map maybe sort of a
this has got layers let's trace our base
why not we've done anything else I hope
this works
oh yeah if you want to join all you
gotta do is join the GameSpot official
steam group yep and from there join the
group chat and you can right click on us
to join up
[Music]
but just said it's three before I can be
on the three team oh we can do that
after yeah we'll do that after we're
taking it taking a slow taking it easy
yeah oh yeah by the way something with
tight corridors yeah well this is got
like it's not super tight corridors but
it's got kind of a little bit you got
those like bridges in between this is
just a really good map got really really
good yeah we got our lock I don't know
if that's good for zombies by thighed
try it
I feel like any time I get caught like
by zombies and I have like an armor lock
ability it's just that I'm standing over
me hitting me and telling right like it
might not actually be effective but it
comes with a shotgun I think they all do
they're on the way this map also works
if it looks like real battle-scarred so
it looks like a zombie invasion has
taken place there you go and thank you
Jake fur for linking the the group again
she just click on there and join up and
come on in the group chat and join a
game I didn't even have a chance to try
it
hey I got god dang it's okay now you get
to play the I kind of like playing the
zombie sounds fun like okay get the role
you go so fast
all right let's uh oh boy not that how I
see this this is the classic holdout
spot inside here that's what they do
it's when you got all the zombies got a
team up firstly fall asleep that's
totally fine to say fall asleep to
YouTube videos is great also calling out
that you can find full g4 TV episodes on
YouTube is also a thing that guy ran to
really I was trying to like Corral
everyone in the corner like we all need
to hi hang up here and then rush um it's
all at once so we got we got people
lined up there you go Oh or uh nevermind
all get picked off yeah you're you're
good Sonic ain't no thang fiction be
active now I bet this is worthless
we're playing this map a lot during the
beta yeah the beta for this was yeah the
beta was this one in power house I still
it's funny air you know aim when you
remember at the beta Maps yeah
the cool thing is like I still have like
montages of beta gameplay 204 my
favorites list I didn't do montages if
we reach I think it did montages for 3d
that oh I I didn't do them I just liked
other people's money
oh no I made montage I this was back in
a time where I'm looking I wish I could
do this and I I think the first time I
ever did like a video thing was live
streaming on livestream calm and like
twice 5 or 2010 I made uh I made halo 3
mission ma hacky that was my thing I
would you mention him a couple of times
I could have find on machinima calm but
unfortunately does not what I kind of I
kind of wanted this
I can't I kind of want to see young John
Lucas halo machine I'll see if I could
there one there probably terrible look
there
I doubt they're funny I bet they're
pretty good oh I used to make comment
they probably they probably got like the
dankest memes of 2008 right like I
remember now the closest thing that I
actually did do was me and my friend
when we used to play Warcraft
actually made comics Oh like web comics
but we did it all in the game oh that's
actually pretty cool like using
screenshots right yeah we took
screenshots and crop them out everything
people used to do that put like text on
them and stuff it was it was a pretty
fun time and yeah that's awesome
we have people guest star who come in
yeah that's great I love that I spent a
lot of time playing one yeah I think a
couple of my mission myself on my
computer I'm all like hard drive but a
couple of them got erased because they
were only on machinima calm and then
that site got shut down yeah whoa
I forgot that when you go invisible like
the sound drops out yeah and it does the
radar thing yeah just cool
remember the Halo 3 beta play that for
like 30 hours straight one weekend I do
the hill 3 beta yeah yeah yeah I just
think you know that you ever wing when
bean is we're like a really big thing
with a halo 3 beta is like famous
because it was the whole crackdown thing
yeah I didn't buy a crackdown I just
rented it that weekend I actually that's
how well I know I did too but like I
eventually went and played all crackdown
but like I rented it just to play the
beta I gained the system but yeah like I
feel like betas don't have like this big
of one minute there's big of a draw to
them anymore maybe it's because like
they happen all the time now or maybe
it's cuz early access is we got a good
amount of people in here heck yeah it's
great so this is us just like this is
coming back from from being away for a
bit you know it's the new year yeah dude
time we're at by the way oh it is 6
ok cool we have a whole half-hour we got
time left this has been a really good
time yeah hey let Hale is always a good
time and I I love that it's one of our
kind of like
our staple games if there's nothing else
going on we can always kind of count on
halo to be like oh yeah for a while it
was actually quick champions yeah that
games kind of dead unfortunately I
haven't hopped in there I'll hop in a
hot minute say have they done anything
like oh I checked I want to say a couple
weeks ago like oh because he used to be
updating it fairly regularly but I
haven't seen any like substantial
upgrade updates like no new maps no new
characters yeah
since the grappling hook girl Athena I
think her name is I like that game quite
a bit actually but I mean if there's no
I'm playing it then yeah there's kind of
no reason though yeah so it kind of runs
dry eventually it's the problem all
right reach actually had a pretty big
drop-off on PC as well I believe it cuz
after the initial like okay I've got
halo on PC now I can play it whenever I
want and then you just kind of like have
it there because it's not new right it's
like yeah but it's very good to have and
oh yeah III think it'll get kind of a
bump each game comes out will get a nice
little bump yeah honestly I'm just
impressed they turned the Master Chief
collection around it was dead for a real
long time on Xbox is it a hard hard read
you said of all that I've worked out
really well cause Troy says they gotta
kill Ian Ayre on video once
Kilian heirs were wild I don't know if I
I gotta kill Ian Ayre like organically I
was killing her at the 25
I think killing there's the the one
where you kill like 12 people in a row
I did get we were playing the other day
like a couple weeks ago or like a month
or two ago ten ten in a row 10 in a row
thanks Sonic I didn't get ten in a row
but I did get like 10 sword kills him
one life and it felt oh so good
unfortunately I was not capping it
that's uh that's a running riot that's
what that is
frederik you're gonna get one more
warning he's already quit
L&T quit all right well she has had to
say one thing and then get out I guess
Smiley's he quit I thought it was like a
little over ten but I it's been so long
I'm I'm good either way
oh it's true we could hit up GTA online
at some point or like read that if it
gets some major updates that's a great
thing any phrase this is open there are
options here do you do I also kind of
like sometimes we kind of do like it's a
community Friday we're playing a big
release but we're all hanging out
together all right
it's not necessarily multiplayer but so
so it's the hardest thing the Duke
community Fridays for is actually betas
because they don't have the systems in
place typically to like get a party it's
just like matchmaking I feel like we've
learned our lesson with those though the
ones does that one have lobbies I keep
thinking about how how fun that stream
was so it was it was just done late in
the day it was right before e3 we're all
like really tired even though we had no
he was good yeah that was caught on
camera people saw that full of it
Brandon also brings up a very good point
with this new sack we can bring more
people on yes that is the other big
reason we upgraded over here is that we
can bring more people on so for example
if we do we do end up doing viola the
next week maybe we could get Jake on if
he's interested this is or max who's
also very good at smash some smash
people in here or informal way of asking
Jake if he wants to play smash next week
there it is right there you go it's
happening it's happening that simple
mics we're using are they sure yes they
are sure are sure sure
it was there I couldn't not do it I like
as soon as you said what it was I like
looked over and saw and I'm like all the
joke is here but yeah sure mics right
this looks like how it's spelled
told you jump in here hey down to the
data point whatever whatever we can to
get people in to play it's it's a good
time I like I like this stream a lot Oh
probably get for walking away it's all
good get too impatient with infection
well I got killed things got a play very
different love red dead 50 on line isn't
this reasons GTA is sure oh it still has
some legs but it definitely doesn't seem
like it's taken off the way GTA did yeah
red dead it's got this weird like what's
not weird I feel like it's got more of
like an emphasis on role playing uh kind
of like a thing that makes me more
excited like all of its it's like
progression is like you are going to be
a bounty on earth and you're gonna go
find bounties or you're gonna be a
person who's like going and hunting
animals and taking their skins and so
there's there's like a role for you to
play in it and GT islands like or on
lines like let's rob a bank and let's go
take out these dudes in this house and
do missions and get money that way and
here's a person with a helicopter that's
got a tank make types the bottom hang
this is a head shot the sniper skills
down nice
also get more practice with Terry got to
work on my banjo - I don't know if I'll
ever be like good with banjo but I love
that he's in and I love him so much
ah smash is good I should play some some
more to kind of get ready if we do do it
next week I think we might I think
probably should probably get get some
smash stuff going we should play smash
in the office in it remaining it's been
a while
it has don't forget to toss the corny er
Witcher good call it easy
very good call just did the arm a lot to
do it Terry's really fun to play in
they're just seconds remaining yep
oh that got any news ventus we got me we
got looking good like they've got some
good defense set up here yeah it's
difficult to penetrate eventually Vince
has got to run out of ammo right that's
usually how it goes
oh no money the wrong time dang well
played humans win this time round over
got a skills Wow the history of this
being a game mode - is really cool like
having like a in fiction like an honor
game mode that people made using the
weird loose rule sets right right and
then have it was in Halo 2 right there
were people were making it up and then
they turn into a real thing and three
Grif balls kind the same thing yeah
this ball is really cool to make our
balls fun sonic so sorry for punching
you in the face
no worries well it's good that they were
getting the apologies Oh an office
tournament we will occasionally do one
for smash yeah we've done that a couple
of times depending on who's there
a lot of time it's usually the same it's
okay man that that's how it goes I'm so
not good at infection there's a lot of
like watching the radar and not looking
ahead of you that has happened then you
end up getting caught up so it's all
good though I appreciate you trying to
fend me
hey oh it's a good color scheme oh yeah
that's a nice color scheme
followed you guys don't know how to play
with you guys so if you want to play you
have to join our GameSpot official steam
group which is how will mmm is this is
like future-proofing this is an
investment if if you join it and I think
how we do all of our steam PC stuff
going forward because once you join you
can join the group chat and then from
the group chat you can also join the
game service be joined the group chat
right click yes start us Crusader I'll
take that cuz sometimes it's like I'm
gonna let myself die so that my buddy
behind me can get the kill let's just I
work sometimes a zombies zombies is all
about finding a way to distract someone
while someone else comes exactly yes so
like in that case I'm like it's not
reflected on the scoreboard but I'll
take it
I know I helped yeah I died he's owed
they may also die
Oh sonica Ventus Oh
Sonic's getting the kills there you go
and I'm coming in from behind yeah once
you're in the steam group then you you
join the group chat how many people does
we have now we've got uh this is a group
you got a good one two four five six
seven is that eight that is eight yeah
sick let's get some team stuff going
then
all right everyone I'm sure the flag
yeah oh that's a good idea
oh you know um have you got to put it on
ion you want to do hemorrhage or what's
it called in this one okay wait so which
version of capture the flag
I always like a bit of one flag but like
traditional CTF with the two flags is is
a good good call for traditional I say
yeah traditional all right let's do it
someone mentioned if we want to do some
customs I'm down I don't unfortunately
have any customs build if you guys have
any recommendations for customs that you
would like us to try I would be more
than happy to do that
so I think I have to go Forge world and
then I have to go yep camera Geoff
let's do it it sounds fun yeah
[Music]
poor world was a very good idea too
I want to do this just for the fun of it
the the the nostalgic feels some people
might say this is a too big too big of a
map for this but I think oh it's just so
much fun yeah yeah you get to drive
around whole bunch more we haven't even
gotten any vehicle stuff yet yeah I'll
be good chance for vehicle stuff alright
hey if more people joined that just
means some people might get some some
extra help
let's try it capture the flag
alright are we on defense behind attack
what we doing so much time affordable
everybody get in your vehicles every
woods rollout they got yeah that too
there we go this is some halo the
distinctive like sound of warthog engine
whoa [ __ ] em up we're already off to a
rough start over there oh boy okay also
there are tanks tanks are tanks beat
everything takes to beat everything oh
dude that's what I love about a caption
waggons that's how it goes you just get
in there it goes horribly yet tanks are
just firing artillery fire from behind
so I assume the snipers not even grabbed
talked here top ten Halo memories
oh yeah go for it I'm just gonna say
like one of my favorite things I
remember from playing I think it was
Halo 3 where he looks you on I'm like
the Blood Gulch map so probably probably
halo 2 then was doing capture the flag
match with my friends it had been going
on forever and I was I had to run the
flag manually down like on foot through
the middle of the map which is stupid
and there was this point where his
person was trying to cite me from across
the map while I was carrying it and at
the front door
I like whiffed around and hit the the
trigger to toss the flag out in front of
me and it actually like the pole of the
the the flag deflected a sniper shot
that definitely would have killed me and
I still remember that like in my head
distinctively and probably one of my
favorite things there we go
flag protector
that wacky Star Wars vehicle is a good
one I played a lot of like split-screen
with my brother and my cousin's whenever
they would like visit we'd play Halo and
I just didn t remember a match where cuz
you know we're playing split-screen so
of course everyone's screen looking and
he was always on all rocket launchers ok
it was on Halo 2 I think on this map and
I my brother was like right in front of
the base so I saw like he was behind the
wall so I said hand behind you and he
just turns around and shoots the wall
and blows himself up oh man oh you need
me let's go oh heck yeah
hey Court how's it goin welcome I know
our Flags my song that's gay this is
when the real CTF happens because now
now they know they've got the flag
they've got to go protect it it's less
about just getting a vehicle and killing
someone
yeah why don't you go punch it yeah yeah
smack her man bring me closer
[Laughter]
who this is this is the danger zone this
is a lot okay
now this is the fun part where you are I
just stand here you've got to try to be
safe I'll socks got me this is good this
is good the stalemate the plays are
happening I feel it leg recover yeah
yeah already off onto a good sonica that
was you bless your heart
that was some fine haloing right there
do it again yeah and then you just
repeat that process all over
also I still wanna throw things like I
control are you on PC uh yeah I actually
got a would agree I did eventually legs
like those I've actually got used to the
pc the pc keyboard and mouse we're gonna
take the teleporter i think yeah where
does that tell it takes you like over
off another right
all right so we got our flag so we just
need to get there like a couple seconds
dropped flag taken get those the flag
drop technology got halo 2 I used to
know how to do like all the the dumb
super bounces and like the flag bounces
across the map
leg wrong leg taken leg okay here we go
and then we're gonna score yeah how do
you feel a little bad because we do
unfortunately have one more person
oh so need someone joined partway
through which is okay that's not a
problem but that's not red team
implanted will advantage red team or
blue team so like in general or or like
spiritually uh and through however you
ever spoon Evert however you want to
all three shirt I feel like I like being
on red team anymore they have that like
mental thing where I know that like in
Halo 2 we had like host advantage
they've always got like priority for
things but I like blue because I feel
like they're more camouflage Bryant it's
like if you're blue team and you're
hiding over in the like shadows of the
rocks on the side of this map it's me
real difficult to see
okay
in a game over with or flag moments like
that the game so much more fun to play I
get really nervous the adrenaline kicks
in oh yeah
sonic do Sonic's on topics on top of it
man
Sonic's Sonic's the wheel man of the
team without a doubt
which makes sense cuz Sonic's gotta go
fast no there you go
it's all we getting it out okay so now
we just got recovered Barfleur was it
good like death yell leg drop Oh toxic
good make it in taken yeah dang fast
there it is
flag recovered flag oh come Hampshire
we haven't been repeating the announcer
we did it nearly enough that was fun I
enjoyed that
capture the flag is always a good time
that was a fun Tyler apologies to blue
team for being one person short ah let's
mix it up again
let's see and we'll give it any
recommendations okay what time we have
we are at 12:17 1217 so we have time for
at least one more man I think one more
what if we just did a giant Messi king
of the her match with ninety seven eight
nine
hey why don't you king of the hill
alright ma'am
sorry everyone's just gonna be going
crazy
[Music]
Hill moves in a random order you have a
crazy kings fast does good crazy game
yeah just make it a like a real crazy
time
what map should we do hmm it's gotta be
it's got to be a good one it's a good
knapford
[Music]
I want to say reflection even though
we've already been there once
this is okay it's it's kind of like a
medium-sized deal but tempest get a
tempest recommendation that's what oh
yeah we'll take the recommendation for
tempest oh heck yeah all right let's do
it
I'm excited for this because it's just
it's just gonna be wild
it's just insane song says who are you
on Steam if they if you don't mind
they'd like to add you but no I started
as a crusader yeah but we said the doing
the stuff from the steam group this
you're just gonna run it all through
here and it's good yeah so if you
specifically want him to friend me to
play like community Friday stuff as long
as they're in the group it seems like
you'll just be able to join which makes
it really easy also what up goob
good to see you it's time to create new
twenty twenty halo means dude yeah I'm
good for 20 20 everyone's gonna be
playing Halo cuz they're gonna be
putting all those things on PC yeah on
PC and then infinite first all right so
now you've got the rocket launcher you
know where the hill is you know what
you've got to do
there we go see it's a good assist Oh
that's that crazy King its moves like
every 30 seconds
all right oh oh well thank you
GUP says hi hello babe
another good one is already moved yeah
it's it's quick like you got a it I like
crazy thing cuz it makes it so that you
have to deal chaotic you have to not
fight people on your way there and just
get there as fast as you can
it's like right now you see this guy
who's coming up on you you guys
shouldn't be fighting each other I agree
you should be you should go over to that
house you get those points
it's probably just ranch rule makes
sense yeah he'll move or you go yeah
where's that perfect there it is babe
you like jet packs to be like drop in on
top of it
yeah yeah give it to me as long as
possible for seconds I'll take it that's
that's half a little less than half of
what the person the lead has so that's
that's a good play something special
about hello ill control but when halos
chaos may explosions going on you have
no idea what's going on show exactly
what to do it's that's why I think big
team is one of the best things I've ever
done
then inhale Lincoln is great it's like
what if we take all the most chaotic
elements of Halo and put them all on one
spot with as many players as we can and
just let it all go on it's it really is
something beautiful
[Applause]
yeah damn and move though it's like that
was it halo region didn't never the
shield bleed through when it first
happens not maybe that's why has it as
variants yeah so remember there was one
of the halos came out without being
through everyone was like what is this
how can you do
no that's our that's our boy not anymore
they're an enemy now
you know I kind of low-key hope happens
this is like a completely random thought
it cannot tie Danny oh yeah you know
that that Jojo battle royale game oh
yeah I hope that like gets localized
[Music]
it's just our kids right now so like oh
okay
but I I'm not sure so I've seen videos
with ps4 button prompts oh okay what I'd
like to do that it's like a it's like a
15 person battle royale
but it's so near Jo some weird mix
yeah its inner also don't see like the
different like main characters use their
abilities right okay
I'm getting up there a little bit
control yes that's how it goes you know
ill control gets gets a little bit crazy
comes together okay this is a good map
choice yeah it's it's a lot of good kind
of back and forth it's open to us that
was thank you
yeah I think we're gonna do some
fighting games for a little bit it seems
like smash Mortal Kombat we might do
granblue ill controlled under nights
under night definitely and then control
you know I do would be a fun one do we
anything that's got an interesting
multiplayer I like the idea of someone
recommending like oh do something around
half-life like do some like half-life
deathmatch or something like that
god I'm dead serious oh I'll play
ricochet for an hour
I'm about it Sonic don't do this man
well played Sonic dang I felt it and I
did the exact same thing you told me not
to do which is like I'm gonna shoot him
when I should just be running for the
hill that's how it goes dangers can live
out my fantasy of murdering Sonic so
this is like a real mosh pit over here
this is dreamy I'm loving this feel
controlled
just kind of watch this Jojo huh I'd say
check it out it's you're just pretty
good I like it it's a real real strong
real strong anime but Jake does just no
animal okay take that how you will
killer also brings up a good point
though Jojo is an anime JoJo's Cho Cho
got transcends anime it kind of does so
I think you might be a right goob
in that respect how it goes in crazy
King I guess oh man
yeah the sock movies out real soon I'm
real excited to see that yeah I like
that the the projections for how much
it's gonna like earn are fairly high and
I wonder if it's just because people are
curious we're doing a group showing at
the office yeah are you going to that
yeah I'm gonna have to I I can't not not
because I'm like even if it sucks it's
the kind of thing where it's like we're
all gonna be there so we can all kind of
have fun with it well we all just sit
there and be like hey guys remember that
sonic movie remember how Jim Carrey I'm
terrible that was or remember how great
it was yeah I still want
I hope the President of the United
States shows up that's what I want there
is this like like the military is hiring
dr. Eggman yeah kind of thing is he
called about necking this one I want the
robot name even though like a cannon
cannon yeah cuz the the initial like
show off stuff like it was set in San
Francisco yeah yeah this is just to
which means he's gonna escape
military police custody oh I won't hop
on a skateboard using part of their a
helicopter oh then he's gonna ride down
San Francisco mark my words if we were
in that showing and see escape starts
playing as he starts running away from
the police I'll cry I'll cry in the
theater and roll my guess is if it would
show up it'll show up in the credits so
I think the credits is that like it's
the like Wiz Khalifa little yawn oh yeah
okay but I could be wrong though
sometimes there are multiple songs
during right yeah that's like a that'll
be like credit song number three yeah
that's like at the very end when you
know the ushers are cleaning up I'll go
slow you're the only guy there waiting
for the post-credits scene and then
cityscape hits and you're like yeah it's
got to be like either the violin version
from generations or it's got to be like
us like a slow melodic piano like
it sounds like The Avengers theme that's
I'm talking about
you mean god heck yeah we mean God but
Oliver seeing it on all the boxes he'll
control what's up a name of a military
or whatever yeah ill control sonic to
shake the president's hand at some point
all I want shoo toxic says that they've
got to go it's all good toxic thank you
for hanging out thank you we're probably
to be wrapping up fairly soon what time
is it it is two minutes until 12:30 then
yeah
this will be our last match so thank you
toxic for playing with us yeah thank you
everyone who's been playing with us this
has been a really really good stream Hey
promo time if you enjoyed what you did
here today or watch today or listen to
today
you should definitely follow the channel
subscribe we have tons of content all
the time
reviews previews all sorts of views that
you always want to never want here we
have things that you want things that
you probably don't want come come on
down but you can always guarantee that
we will have a live stream every day at
11 a.m. Pacific JEP playing games that
are relevant or not relevant or games
with you
like we are today on community Fridays
yeah all right that is it that is the
end of halo Jake cut toufool cam will
close out the stream here so yeah as Ben
said you can follow us if you want to
see more great streams we really
appreciate everyone who played with us
today it's fantastic we do this every
Friday at 11:00 a.m. the same time like
we said we probably can do smash next
week yeah I'm thinking that's a pretty
strong bet so if you want to play some
smash with us then be sure to tune back
in next week yeah I think it's about it
thanks for joining us guys have a good
weekend
[Music]